نعم تفضل
مؤمن مؤمن انت معنا مؤمن
الشراسيف
اجواء من الحزن تخيم على مستشفى غزه
الاوروبي في مدينه خان يونس في وداع
الزميلين حمزه وائل الدحدوح وايضا الزميل
مصطفى ثريا بعد قصف اسرائيلي بصاروخ من
طائره مسيره اسرائيليه استهدف السياره
التي كان يستقلها الزميلين خلال تغطيتهما
الصحفيه للغارات والقصف الاسرائيلي الذي
استهدف منطقه ميراج التي تقع الى الشمال
الشرقي من مدينه رفح هذه المنطقه طيله
ليله امس كانت تشهد سلسله من الغارات
الاسرائيليه استهدفت مبنى سكني كان يؤوي
نازحين وايضا اراضي زراعيه يقيم فيها
النازحون خياما ذهبوا في ساعات الصباح
الباكر
لتغطيه هذهه المنطقه والاحداث التي جرت في
هذه المنطقه خلال ساعات الليل والتي كانت
تستهدف في جلها مدنيين نازحين اثناء
توجههم الى تلك المنطقه بغدت طائره مسيره
اسرائيليه بصاروخ واحد على الاقل استهدف
السياره التي كان يستقلانها ما ادى الى
ارتقاء الزميلين و حمزه وائل الدحدوح
وايضا مصطفى ثريه شهيدان نتيجه هذه
الغاره الاستهداف الاسرائيلي لجموع
الصحفيين وعائلاتهم لا يتوقف منذ بدايه
هذه الحرب والتي تخطت يومها الت0 نتحدث عن
109 صحفيين استشهدوا منذ بدايه الحرب
نتيجه القصف والغارات والاستهداف
الاسرائيلي المباشر والمتعمد
لهم مؤسسات صحفيه نددت بالجريمه
الاسرائيليه الجديده بحق الصحفيين طالبت
المجتمع الدولي بضروره الوقوف امام
مسؤولياتهم لحمايه الصحفيين طالبت ايضا
الامم المتحده والصليب الاحمر وجميع
المنظمات الدوليه
بضروره الضغط على سلطات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي لوقف استهداف المتعمد للصحفيين
الفلسطينيين وعائلاتهم اي ايضا هنا حاله
من الحزن تخيم على جموع الصحفيين بفقد
شهيدين جديدين نتيجه الغارات الاسرائيليه
التي لا تستهدف فقط الصحفيين بل جميع
المدنيين هنا في خانيونس كانت مجزره
ارتكبتها في ساعات الليل قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي بعد قصف عائله بريص القريبه
منزلها قريب هنا من مستشفى ناصر نتحدث عن
27 شهيد من هذه العائله عندما كنت في
ساعات الصباح الباكر اطالع اسماء الشهداء
لابحث بالاحصائيات
دمت بان 14 طفلا من اصل 27 شهيد هم من
الاطفال لا يتجاوز عمر اكبرهم 10 سنوات
بالاضافه الى اربع سيدات النيران
والصواريخ والقصف الاسرائيلي و والحمم
التي تطلقها الطائرات الاسرائيليه على
مختلف المناطق في القطاع من شمالي الى
جنوبه لا تستثني احدا لا تستثني الصحفي
ولا الطفل ولا المراه ولا حتى المستشفيات
والمرافق الطبيه وايضا المسعفين ورجال
الدفاع المدني الجميع في مرمى النار
الاسرائيليه في ظل صمت دولي مريب في ظل
اعداد كبيره من النازحين مدينه رفح لوحدها
نصف سكان قطاع غزه اكثر من مليون نسمه
نزحوا الى مدينه رفح هذه المدينه الحدوديه
البسيطه التي لا تتوفر فيها مقومات
لاستقبال هذا العدد الهائل من النازحين
الاطفال يفترشون الارض خيام بسيط في
الشوارع من النيلون الرقيق لا تقيهم
برد الليل وجرائم الاحتلال تحدث على مراه
ومسمع من العالم دون ان يحرك احد ساكنا
لتوفير الحمايه سواء للصحفيين او
ل المدنيين هنا او لسكان القطاع حتى
المساعدات التي تتحدث عنها الامم المتحده
وتحدث عنها المجتمع الدولي هي مساعدات
قليله جدا بشهاده المفوض العام للام
للمروه بنفسه يقول ان المساعدات التي تدخل
الى القطاع هي مساعدات قليله مقارنه مع
حجم الماساه التي يعيشها اكثر من 2 مليون
نسمه في القطاع تتحدث عن نحو 23000 شهيد
نتحدث عن اكثر من 9000 مفقود نتحدث عن
الاف اخرين لازالوا تحت ركام منازلهم لا
تستطيع لا فرق الاسعاف ولا الدفاع المدني
و ولا احد انتشالهم ل لدف دفنهم نتيجه
الاستهداف الاسرائيلي المتعمد لسياره
الاسعاف وايضا تدمير اليات وممتلكات
وادوات جهاز الدفاع المدني الماساه هنا في
غزه هي ماساه كبيره تفوق الوصف ما
تشاهدونه من صور وما تنقله عدسات الكاميرا
هي جزء بسيط بسيط جدا من حجم الماساه وهول
الضمار الذي خلفته الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه في مناطق متفرقه من قطاع غزه
احياء كامله مد مناطق سكنيه كامله مسحت عن
وجه الارض لا توجد مع مدينه غزه لا توجد
لها اي معالم بحسب الصور القليله التي ترد
من من هناك شمال قطاع غزه مخيم جباليا بيت
حنون بيت لاهيه المنطقه الوسطى التي تدك
منذ نحو اسبوع وحتى هذه اللحظه عبر
الغارات الجويه والقصف المدفعي وتدمير
المنازل حتى مدارس الانرو التي كانت تؤوي
النازحين قصفت بالمدفعيه الاسرائيليه
واستشهد المئات من النازحين اسرائيل تدفع
بسكان قطاع غزه عبر تكثيف الغارات والقصف
المدفعي والجوي وايضا البحري للنزوح اتجاه
مدينه رفح الحدوديه في مدينه في المنطقه
الوسطى بمخيمات النصيرات والبريج والمغازي
جميع 90% من سكان هذه المناطق نزحوا
باتجاه دير البلح او المنطقه الجنوبيه
باتجاه مدينه رفح جنوبي القطاع شكرا لك
مؤمن اشرافي من خان يونس